اتهم الحرس الثوري الايراني السعوديه
بالمسؤوليه عن هجومين استهدف مبنى
البرلمان وضريح الخميني في طهران وتوعد
الحرس الثوري بان ايران ستنتقم من منفذي
الهجومين وداعميه ما في الوقت نفسه رفض
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه عادل الجبير
الاتهام قائلا انه لا دليل
عليه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا كان هذا خبر حلقتنا
ونناقش فيما وراءه ما الذي يمكن قراءته من
توقيت الهجومين وهدف ايهما في قلب طهران
وما هي التداعيات المرتقبه بعد اتهام
طهران للسعوديه ونفي الاخيره
[موسيقى]
مسؤوليتها بعد سنوات لم تشهد فيها ايران
تفجيرات تذكر ضد اهداف استراتيجيه في
طهران جاء الهجوم المزدوج على البرلمان
وضريح الامام الخميني في قلب العاصمه
الايرانيه ليطرح اسئله عده عن دلالات
التوقيت والاماكن المستهدفه كما يلاحظ
ايضا لهجه الاتهام والتهديد التي
استخدمتها طهران ومصارعته بتحميل
المسؤوليه للرياض التي سارعت بدورها الى
النفي تقرير احمد
مرزوق في الماضي وفي الوقت الذي كانت فيه
التفجيرات تضرب الولا مختلفه في العالم من
حين لاخر كانت ايران من بين الدول التي
ينظر فيها وقوع مثل تلك العمليات وكان ذلك
يدفع البعض للتساؤل لماذا ايران لكن وبعد
اكثر من سبع سنوات من اخر عمليه وقعت فيها
شهدت طهران عمليتين منفصلتين مكانا
متزامنتين في التوقيت وصف بانهما الاق منذ
عقود 12 قتيلا حسب ما اعلنته اداره
الطوارئ الايرانيه هو عدد ضحايا العمليتين
التين ضربت قلب العاصمه الايرانيه طهران
واستهدفت مبنى البرلمان ومجمع
الخميني وكانت هيئه الاذاعه والتلفزيون
الايرانيه قالت ان الهجوم على البرلمان
الذي وقع صباح الاربعاء قد انتهى وان
المهاجمين الاربعه قتلوا من جانبه اعلن
محافظ طهران ان قوات الامن قد احد مهاجم
ضريح الخميني بينما فجر مسلح اخر حزامه
الناسف في الضريح واعتقل مسلح ثالث وفي
اليوم نفسه تبنى تنظيم الدوله العمليتين
بل بثت وكاله اعماق التابعه للتنظيم صورا
قالت انها بعدسه احد المهاجمين داخل مبنى
البرلمان الايراني لكن بيانا للحرس الثوري
الايراني اشار باصابع الاتهام الى اطراف
اخرى قائلا ان من الواضح ان لامريكا
والسعوديه دورا في الهجوم وانه لن يمر دون
رد وان ايران ستنتقم من منفذيه وداعميه
حسب البيان لكن وزير الخارجيه السعودي
عادل الجبير نفى تلك الاتهامات وقال انه
لا يوجد دليل على ان السعوديين مسؤولون عن
تلك الهجمات وفي اول رد فعل سياسي قال
رئيس البرلمان الايراني علي لاريجاني ان
تلك الهجمات لن تؤثر على سياسات
بلاده ما يؤشر الى ان هدف الارهابيين هو
جلب الانظار وخلق مشكله لايران باعتبارها
قطبا فعالا ونشيطا في الحرب على الارهاب
في المنطقه هذا الهجوم الارهابي يريد ضرب
سياسات البلاد التي تواجه الارهاب وهذا لن
يحصل فالقوى الامنيه تتصدى لهم بجديه ولن
تكون هناك اي مشكلات واكد ارجاني ان بلاده
ستواصل حربها على الارهاب داخل وخارج
ايران على حد
قوله لمناقشه
هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من طهران حسين
ريوان الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون الاقليميه
وعبر الهاتف ينضم الينا الدكتور عبد الله
الشاجي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه
الكويت ابدا معك سيد حسين
ريوان لنتحدث اولا في توقيت
هذه العمليه هذين
الهجومين ما دلاله الهجومين الذين اتيا في
وقيت حساس ازمه خليجيه على مستوى العلاقات
اتهام لطهران بالارهاب وبعد طبعا زياره
ترامب الى
المنطقه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم يعني في
التوقيت ان هذه العمليه تاتي
يعني بعد فتره قصيره
من مؤتمر الرياض واعلان الحرب ضد ايران وا
يعني هذا التوقيت لا يمكن ان يكون يعني
ا
مصادفه اعلان الحرب ضد طهران في مؤتمر
الرياض هو يعكس اراده سياسيه لدى الحكومه
السعوديه مدعوم امريكيا في استهداف الامن
في الداخل الايراني وطبيعي ان هذا لم يكن
الموقف الاول هناك مواقف كثيره من قبل
المسؤولين السعوديين عبروا فيها عن ان
الامن الايراني مستهدف خلال السنه الماضيه
يعني وزاره الامن الايراني اعتقلت اكثر من
عشره مجاميع حاولت القيام بعمليات ارهابيه
في ايران من من هنا ايران كانت في دائره
الاستهداف ولكن الظروف لم تسمح لهذه
المجموعات بالقيام بعمليه ولكن الاختراق
حدث اليوم حدث اليوم وا يعني استهدف
مركزين لهما رمزيه سياديه ورمزيه دينيه
وثوريه وحاول نقل رساله ان ايران مستهدفه
من قبل هذه التيارات الارهابيه دكتور عبد
الله الشاجي ماذا تقول انت في هذا التوقيت
ل الهجومين في
طهران يعني طبعا ما حدث اليوم ملفت جدا في
ثلاث ابعاد في اعتقادي البعد الاول هو
توقيته والبعد الثاني رمزيته
لاستهداف مرقد الخميني وال مبنى مجلس
الشورى البرلمان والبعد الثالث
ادعاء بشكل سريع داعش دون ان تقدم اي ادله
بمن قام به عاده تضع صور وفيديو وال ما
يسمى جنود الخلافه ومصارعه الحرس الثوري
وليس الحكومه الايرانيه بتوجيه اصابع
الاتهام الى ال المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتدبير
هذا الهجوم اذا اذا استثنينا نظريه ان هذه
كما يروج الان في وسائط التواصل الاجتماعي
في كثير من الدول العربيه
والخليجيه بان ما جرى هو عمليه مسرحيه
قامت بها الحكومه الايرانيه نفسها اي وانا
طبعا لا اؤمن بذلك بقدر ما اؤمن بان هناك
اربع نظريات
سقطت الان اذا بالفعل هذه العمليه هي
عمليه ارهابيه كما يبدو في الظاهر
ومن تدبير ومن تنفيذ داعش فهناك اربع
نظريات او خمسه يمكنني ان اسردها بشكل
سريع نظريه الاولى بان التي سقطت ان يعد
هذا اختراق امني
كبير يحمل المسؤولين في النظام الايراني
مسؤوليه كبيره على هذا الاختراق لانه ضرب
قلب الاقان المح حصنه وكذلك مرقد الامام
الخميني مؤسس الجمهوريه الاسلاميه النظريه
الثانيه ان ايران قدمت نفسها واحه من
الامن والاستقرار في اقليم مضطرب فيه
صراعات وحروب والنظريه الثالثه ان تدخلات
ايران الخارجيه واسال الحرس الثوري ودورها
في سوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن هو
لمحاربه الارهابيين والتكفيريين حتى لا
ياتوا ويضربون في عقر دارنا والنظريه
الاخيره التي يعني يتهم بها خصوم ايران في
الدول العربيه وفي الخارج بان ايران بان
بان داعش هي صنيعه
المخابرات الايرانيه والدول الاخرى
الحليفه لها فان هذا لم يعد الان بامكان
احد ان يتهم ايران بانها ضربت داعش في كل
المناطق المحيطه بايران واستثنت ايران
فايران الان تقدم نفسها انها ضحيه وانها
ايضا ستقوم بالمزيد من العن لمحاربه
التطرف والارهاب والتكفيريين وهذا سنارى
يمكن في في السؤال القادم ما هي ردود
الفعل الايرانيه وكيف ستر طب هذا الموضوع
الموضوع الاخر هذه الجمله نعم حسن اني فقط
هذه المداخله سريعا بان بالفعل ما جرى
اليوم في ايران يعد نقطه فارقه سواء نتفق
او لا نتفق بان ما جرى هو يعني مدبرا ولكن
يعني هناك الان تحولات كبيره وايضا هناك
طبعا اليوم كان في كان في مقاش في مجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي لفرض المزيد من العقوبات
على ايران وهذا قد يتاجل الان بسبب
العمليه الارهابيه طيب ربما ندخل في في
بعض التفاصيل ندخل في بعض التفاصيل لكن
قبل ذلك اعيد ان اريد ان اعود الى السيد
ريوان من طهران بالنسبه للهدف سيد حسين
لهدف هذه العمليه بالتحديد الان ايران كيف
تقراها بغض النظر عن الاتهام الذي وجهه
الحرس الثوري ل السعوديه الهدف من
اي هذا الهجوم كما تراه
ايران يعني لا شك ان الهدف من هذا الهجوم
هو النيل من الامن الايراني يعني زعزعه
الامن في ايران وهذا واضح يعني استهداف
مثلا مجلس الشورى الاسلامي
اي له رمزيه بالنهايه هو يمثل الشعب ممثلي
الشعب موجودون في هذه المؤسسه واستهداف
هذه المؤسسه هو استهداف لرمز سيادي في
داخل ايران
اي رغم ان يعني الاجراءات الامنيه في هذه
المؤسسه لحد اليوم كانت هي سهله باعتبار
ان يجب ان يكون هناك تواصل كبير بين الناس
وبين من يمثلونهم ويوميا هناك الالاف كان
ممن ياتي الى المجلس وير راجع
ممثلي المدن
المختلفه يعني مرقد الامام الخميني ايضا
له رمزيه كبيره رغم ان يعني الموقع مفتوح
بشكل عام لكل من يريد زياره الموقع ليس
هناك من قيود اساسا في هذا الاطار نعم سيد
ران انت تقول بانه الهدف هو زعزعه الامن
لكن اعتقد انك انتبهت جيدا لما قاله
الدكتور عبد الله الشايجي قبل
قليل في جزء م قاله تبدو ايران وكانها
مستفيده بشكل او باخر من هذه الهجمات على
الاقل انها تبعد اي شبهه اي شبهه علاقه
بينها وبين تنظيم الدوله ثم ايضا تبعد
القول بان كل الاماكن مستهدفه باستثناء
ايران هذه الان ايران معرضه ايضا لعمليات
ارهابيه ما رايك في
ذلك يعني اولا ان يعني احتمال ان تكون
هناك علاقات بين ايران وبين داعش هذا
مرفوض جمله وتفصيلا ايران منذ عده سنوات
وهي تحارب هذه التيارات التكفيريه من هنا
النقيضان لا يجتمعان ولا يرتفعان لا يمكن
ان تكون ايران داعمه لداعش وتحارب داعش في
نفس الوقت يعني هذا كلام مرفوض وغير مقبول
و يعني في السنه الماضيه كما ذكرت اكثر من
عشره مجاميع
تم اعتقالها من قبل وزاره الامن الايرانيه
وكلها كانت تحاول زعزعه الامن
اي الايراني وهذا يعكس ان العداء بين
ايران وداعش هو قائم ايران ليست بحاجه الى
دفع شبهه قائمه هذه الشبهه موجوده يعني قد
تكون في الاذهان المريضه التي تحاول يعني
ايجاد علاقه بين ايران وبين هذه التيارات
ايران حاربت التيارات التكفيريه سيون سيد
يرون عندما عندما
تتسلط تسلط الاضواء على ايران على اعتبار
انها داعمه للارهاب وغير ذلك ويكون هناك
مؤتمرات دوليه تسلط الضوء على ايران في
هذا المجال وياتي هذا التفجير ليضع ايران
في
دائره الارهاب الا تكون ايران بشكل او
باخر قد استفادت اذا كان الاتهام هنا
للمملكه العربيه السعوديه بالقيام بهذا
التفجير معنى ذلك بان المملكه تخدم ايران
بتفجير من هذا النوع لانها تبعد عنها تهمه
الارهاب يعني اتصور انك اجبت على السؤال
حتى يعني اولا لماذا اولا الاتهام
للسعوديه اولا هل تريد السعوديه خدمه
ايران طبيعي لا السعوديه تعادي ايران
تستعدي ايران ولكن لماذا الاتهام ياتي
سريعا من قبل الحرس الثوري ضد السعوديه هو
ياتي لخلفيه قائمه يعني عندما يلتقي مسؤول
امني كبير مثل تركي الفيصل مع السيده مريم
رجوي يعني وقيادات منظمه مجاهدي خلق في
فرنسا يدعو هذه المنظمه الارهابيه
لاستئناف عملياتها في ايران عندما ياتي
ولي ولي العهد السعودي ويعلن ان ان
السعوديه تريد نقل يعني المعركه الى الى
داخل ايران يعني هذا ايضا ملفت عندما ياتي
ترامب الى السعوديه وتعلن الحرب ضد ايران
يعني كل هذه المؤشرات هل يمكن ان نتجاهلها
ونقول ان
يعني ما حدث هو غير مرتبط بالسعوديه هذا
غير ممكن يعني الحال الصحيح انه التحقيقات
الان بدات وهي ستكشف الخطوط يعني ومن وراء
هذه العمليه ولكن كل ه هذه الوقائع هي
تخدم هذه النظريه ان السعوديه وراء زعزعه
الامن في ايران دكتور عبد الله الشاجي ما
رايك في ذلك مع ان التحقيقات لم تنتهي لبل
هي بدات للتو لكن المؤشرات التي تحدث عنها
تذهب في هذا
الاتجاه يعني خلنا اخ حسن ناكد على نقطتين
النقطه الاولى اننا نحن لا نزال نخط حرب
بارده في الطرف الخليجي والعربي بالرغم من
الازمه مع قطر الان وبالرغم من يعني
الاوضاع داخل البيت الخليجي الذي نامل ان
نتوصل الى المزيد من من طراس الجبهه
الخليجيه الا ان هناك حرب بارده تدور صار
لها سنوات بين دول المستع الخليجي بقياده
السعوديه وبين ايران وتمثلت بقطع العلاقات
وسحب السفراء وقطع العلاقات التجاريه و
مقاطعه ايران لموسم الحج وغيرها الكلام
بان السعوديه طالعه او لها دور و مسارعه
الحرس الثوري الايراني دون ان يجري تحقيقا
او ينتهي التحقيق اتهام السعوديه وزياره
ترامب كانت وراء ذلك ولقاءات تركي الفيصل
الذي لا يمثل الحكومه السعوديه هو رجل
عادي
الان لا يعني لا تساعد ايضا بل يعني مثل
ما ذكرت في سؤالك بان ايران ستحول هذه
العمليه الارهابيه الى فرصه الى فرصه تقدم
نفسها الها ضحيه الى فرصه تنزع عنها ان
لها علاقه بداعش قد لا تكون ايران انشات
داعش ولكن سياسات ايران وا اذرعها
وحلفائها في المنطقه والتجييش الطائفي وال
والحشد الشعبي وما يقوم به ضد السنه في
المناطق المختلفه ونظام الاسد واستهداف
المناطق والمدن السنيه ودعم ايران ومباركه
ايران وتدريب ايران واحضار الميليشيات
زينبيون وفاطم من باكستان ومن
افغانستان لمقاتله المناطق والمدن والسنه
هذا كل له يعطي داعش التي لا تمثل الاسلام
بالنسبه الى الى قطاع واسع من العالم
السني يعطي داعش الفرصه لان يقول نحن نريد
ان نحمي السنه من ايران ومن اذرعها فلهذا
السبب سياسات ايران الان هي التي سمحت
لداعش بان تقوى وتنمى وتكبر او عدم
مقاتلتها كما عندما سقطت الموصل لماذا لم
يقاتل يعني رئيس الوزراء في ذلك الوقت
المالكي ولماذا ل سمح نظام
الاسد دون ان يكون هناك رده فعل فهذه
السياسات الان ستوضع على المحك ولكن ايران
ستقدم نفسها انها ضحيه وانها غير مستثناه
الارها وستقوم باستغلال ذلك للمزيد من
التقدم والتدخل ولعب دور انها الضحيه
عليها ان تنتقم كما ذكر الحلس الثوري من
وم مقطه التحديد نعم موضوع موضوع ما قلته
تنتقم الحرس الثوري يقول يا يتحدث عن الرد
هذه النقطه بعد الفاصل مشاهدينا سناتي على
نقاشها التداعيات المرتقبه بعد اتهام
طهران للسعوديه ونفي الاخيره مسؤوليتها
ابقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا في هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تفجيرات طهران واتهام الحرس
الثوري للسعوديه ونفي
الرياض المسؤوليه سيد حسين ريوان من جديد
اليك لماذا الحرس
الثوري هو
الذي قام بالاتهام مباشره قبل التحقيقات
اجبت عن عن بعض المؤشرات كما تراها طهران
ولكن هو الذي قال بانه سيتم الانتقام
اييه من المنفذين
وداعميه ما وهنا واضح من هو المقصود كيف
سيكون الانتقام
باختصار يعني اولا في ايران هناك جيش
وهناك حرس ثوري يعني هناك مؤسستان من
القوى يعني المسلحه ال الجيش هو مسؤول عن
حفظ الحدود حدود ايران مع الخارج والحرس
هو المسؤول عن الامن الداخلي اذا هناك
تقسيم عمل في هذا الاطار استهداف الامن
الداخلي من قبل داعش في ما حدث اليوم من
عمليات ارهابيه هو استهداف لدور الحرس في
يعني فرض الامن في الداخل من هنا الحرس هو
المسؤول الاول في هذا الاستهداف ومن هنا
يعني الحرس من موقعه كما مسؤول عن الامن
هو يتهم
السعوديه من خلال يعني المؤشرات التي
ذكرتها يعني هناك اراده سياسيه لدى القاده
السعوديين في استهداف الامن في ايران وهذا
واضح من التصريحات والمواقف ولكن هل هذا
الان يعني من خلال التحقيقات سيثبت او لا
هذه هذه مساله
يعني سالتك عن الانتقام وشكل
الانتقام يعني في تصوري الانتقام هو سيكون
في ضمن اطار تشديد الحرب ضد الارهاب ايران
عضو اساسي في الحرب ضد الارهاب ولكن الان
ايران تمتلك حوافز جديده في توسيع دائره
الحرب ضد الارهاب من يمول الارهاب ومن
يحتضن الحاضنه الاساسيه
للارهاب دكتور عبد الله الشايجي اي
تداعيات يمكن ان تنجم عن هذا الاتهام وعن
التهديد بال انتقام ممن قام او دعم هذين
التفجيرين في ثلاث ابعاد في اعتقاد البعد
الا طبعا ايران النقطه الرئيسيه لا تواجه
بشكل مباشر ايران دوله براغماتيه ذكيه
استثمرت على مدى 30 عاما باذرع مهمه من
افغانستان الى الى سوريا ولبنان واليمن
والعراق الان اربع عواصم عربيه كما تفاخر
تخضع لنفوذ ايران فايران لن لن تقوم بشكل
مباشر باي عمليه ولكن ايران تملك اوراق
قوه استثمرت بما تملكه قد نرى ولن يكون
الرد سريعا ومباشرا بل يمكن سياخذ اشهر
ولهذا السبب قد نرى تطورات في الازمه الان
التي ناجمه في قطع العلاقات مع قطر تحاول
استماله قطر اكثر التي الان تشعر بحصار
وتشعر بانها معزوله في عمقها الخليجي فقطر
هي احد النقاط قاط الالتقاء التي يمكن
لايران ان تستثمر فيها القطيف في المنطقه
الشرقيه في المملكه العربيه السعوديه نرى
دور اكبر وتصعيد اكبر لايران مع الحوثيين
في اليمن نار دور اكبر لايران في سوريا
وفي العراق يعني ايران تملك الكثير من
الاوراق واذا ارادت ان تستغل وتحول هذه
العمليه الارهابيه الى فرصه و وتعاطف ايضا
معها خاصه في شهر رمضان واعتداء مهم على
رمزين للسياده ورمز
لطريح الخميني ومبنى مجلس الشورى البرلمان
فايران الان تستطيع ان تلعب بذكاء اوراقها
لتكسب تعاطف ولتزيد من عمليات ما تسميه
الحرب ضد الارهاب والتنظيمات التكفيريه
وتلعب عده ادوار فلهذا السبب الرد
الايراني لن يكون مباشرا سيكون ذكيا
تكتيكيا وايضا ستحاول ان تحرج الطرف الاخر
في الحرب البارده خاصه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه التي الان الرئيس ترامب وامريكا
تقف يعني بشكل واضح للضغط على ايران
واليوم مثل ما قلت كان مفروض يكون في
قانون جديد يضغط اكثر على ايران في في
مجلس الشيوخ الايراني بفرض المزيد من
العقوبات وهذا ايضا قد يكون جزء من
المناورات
الايرانيه لتحويل هذا هذا العمل الارهابي
الى فرصه تستغلها و و يعني تزيد من اوراق
ضغطها وقوتها في المنطقه سيد ري يعني من
خلال الاتهام والتوعد بالانتقام والرد وكل
طرف يتهم الاخر بانه داعم للارهاب وانه هو
الارهاب وغير ذلك الا يدل هذا على ان هذا
المصطلح مصطلح الارهاب اصبح مصطلحا يستثمر
من اي طرف بغض النظر من كان هذا الطرف
يستثمر من قبله لتحقيق مصالح سياسيه او
لتحقيق مصالح امنيه لدى هذه الجهه او تلك
الجهه ف فتصبح الارهاب او يصبح الارهاب
شماعه لدى هذه الدول لتستفيد منها او لتبت
الاخرين
بها نعم مع الاسف الشديد ليس هناك تعريف
واضح للارهاب كانت هناك مؤتمرات كبيره على
المستوى الدولي في بدايه التسعينات لتحديد
موضوع الارهاب ولكن هناك دول تستعمل
الارهاب كاداه من هنا رفضت ان تحدد
الارهاب يعني ما رايناه في مؤتمر الرياض
من اعلان حماس وحزب الله وهو منظمتان
مقاومتان ضد الاحتلال الصهيوني انها منظمه
ارهابيه كيف يتم هذا التعريف وعلى اي اساس
يعني لحد الان مع الاسف ليس هناك من تعريف
واضح المعالم في هذا الاطار المحددات
مختلف عليها ولكن انا في تصوري ان يعني
الارهاب هو استهداف المدنيين طيب وهذا لا
يحدث هنا اس هذه النثير من القوى الموجوده
نعم دكتور عبد الله باختصار باختصار شديد
ما رايك في هذه النقطه بالتحديد الارهاب
الذي يتحول الى شماعه لدى اي طرف
للاستفاده
منه
باقتصاد طبعا الارهاب للاسف اصبح شماع
تستغله جميع الدول الان بشكل واضح لتبرير
سياساتها وخرق حقوق الانسان ويعني داعش
للاسف تحولت الى شماعه تبيد بها الانظمه
في كثير من احيان المدنيين ومدنهم وتسويها
بالارض ولا يوجد تعريف صحيح عن الارهاب
لان هناك اهداف اخرى يعني هناك ارهاب
الافراد ارهاب الجماعات والميليشيات وهناك
ارهاب الدول فكل هذا ارهاب ولا يمكن ان
نفرق عن بعضه البعض شكرا لك دكتور عبد
الله الشازي استاذ العلوم السياسيه في
جامعه الكويت واشكر من طهران حسين روران
الباحث المتخصص في الشؤون الاقليميه نهايه
حلقتنا شكرا لكم والى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا